Chicago Police say they are reviewing a
controversial sting operation amid
growing criticism that their approach
interrupts minorities cell phone video
shows officers leaving behind what
they're calling a bait truck in the
city's Southside neighborhood of
Englewood it is filled with expensive
name-brand shoes three men were arrested
Adriana Diaz spoke with residents who
believe officers tried to lure them into
committing a crime
Adriana good morning to you good morning
cargo thefts at places like this rail
yard are a major problem in Chicago
burglars have you been broken into
containers here with brand new firearms
inside leading to more guns on the
streets to crack down on thefts police
launched an operation trailer trap which
activists call unethical menacing that
police pulled a molten SC it looked like
a routine traffic stop on Chicago's
South Side police pulled over this cargo
truck last Friday then appeared to
arrest the driver as part of a sting
operation he's showing it took him away
left the truck ain't no lock on the back
of the truck so they want somebody go in
and mess with the truck the day before
residents say they saw the same vehicle
parked on a different Street this time
police arrested a man who they say broke
into the unmarked semi then I got a bait
truck but the guy he was looking for
something to eat he was community
activist Charles Mackenzie believes
police were using a truck filled with
expensive Nike and Louboutin shoes to
entrap residents in a poor neighborhood
so you feel like the police is targeting
this community yes they want us to build
a relationship with them but when they
start pulling tricks out up they see me
out they sleeve like this okay trust me
Chicago Police Superintendent Eddie
Johnson said operation trailer trap was
led by the Norfolk Southern Railroad
police with Chicago police assisting
they have been experienced a lot of
theft of firearms over there so we have
a responsibility to keep these firearms
off the street and out of the hands of
the wrong people many members of this
community say this is not helping this
is hurting this is straining relations I
understand that which is why I said
we're going to take a hard look at it
Norfolk Southern Railroad said there's a
lot of misinformation about the
operation noting the three men who were
arrested were seen on surveillance
videos cutting open the
trailer safety seals and attempting to
run off with the shoes inside at the end
of the day someone shouldn't break into
a truck right yes that's wrong but if
you put something in a community when no
one have nothing to do what no money
what's this play Chicago is the nation's
largest rail hub a nationwide cargo
thefts accounted for nearly twenty seven
million dollars in losses in 2016 the
numbers down according to the security
network cargo net except for here in
Illinois were thefts are up Vlad Adriana
Diaz thank you so much for your
reporting